STEPHANIE HANNON: Hi everyone.
My name is Stephanie Hannon.
I work on social impact.
Among other things,
we have a lot
of projects around
civic innovation.
And we are really,
really proud to be
a partner and collaborator
with Code for America,
and welcome our luminary guest
speaker today, Jenn Pahlka.
She's the founder
of Code for America.
She was recently the US Deputy
Chief Technology Officer--
I worked hard to memorize her
title-- of the United States,
and has been pioneering
the use of technology,
entrepreneurs,
coders, visionaries,
to go work in
government, and tackle
some of our hardest
civic problems.
And she came to tell us today
about the Code for America
Summit.
It was a really big event
that happened a few weeks ago,
that brought together more
than 800 people who participate
in this community, and 130
cities were represented.
It was an epic three-day
event, with lots
of amazing collaboration.
And she's going to tell us all
about the work going on today.
So, welcome Jenn.
JENNIFER PAHLKA: Thank
you so much, Stephanie.
[APPLAUSE]
And hello in there.
I'm very excited to be here.
We have a very special
relationship with Google,
and have had support from Google
from the very beginning of Code
for America, and continue
to be a beneficiary
in many, many ways, of this
wonderful organization.
So thank you very much.
I did this Ted Talk a
couple of years ago.
And afterwards an editor of
Wired came up to me and said,
I'm so glad your talk was
good, because I saw that
on the schedule, and
I thought, that's
the perfect time for
me to go do meetings.
But apparently, I
had convinced him
that government was innovative.
I don't think that
those of us who
know the history of
the technology industry
should think of this
as such a stretch,
because of course,
things like GPS
are due to government platforms.
We would not have
the mobile phones
we have today, the services
that we have that use
location, if the
government hadn't invested
in this technology, but more
importantly, opened it up
to civilian use.
So Tim O'Reilly, who's
here with us today,
has that great line,
that Ronald Reagan
is the father of Foursquare.
Because it was
under him that GPS
was opened up to civilian use.
And of course, you
guys all know better.
But many people, if you ask them
where they get their weather,
they believe it comes
from Yahoo or Google.
It comes from the National
Oceanic and Atmospheric
Administration, at great
cost of taxpayer dollars.
And it's served out
through these platforms.
This is a great
example of, I think,
government enabling innovation
in the private sector,
for which we don't
give it much credit.
But the reason
people still give me
a hard time about this
notion of government
innovation, of course, is that
we don't believe that it's
really in and of itself
innovative today.
And I think that the
three major things
that folks need to
understand if they're
going to believe that
government is innovative.
And the first one is
something that, yes,
is a bit of a stretch today,
that interfaces to government--
digital interfaces
to government--
can be simple, beautiful,
and easy to use.
We need to believe that
participating in government
means offering your hands,
not just your voice--
not just complaining,
but offering to help,
or being able to help.
You guys can see
me there, I think.
And that the government
can be more--
not like a tech startup
or a tech company,
but more like the
internet itself--
that solutions can
come from anywhere,
and they can spread very
easily where they need to be.
So I like to sell,
as an example,
a story from our second
year of Code for America,
when we had a team of
fellows-- these are developers
and designers, who
take a year off.
It's their service year.
They're wanting to give
back to their country.
And they went to Honolulu.
We do this partnership
with local governments,
and we had the
privilege of going
to the city and
county of Honolulu--
actually a very large city.
You probably don't realize
it's almost a million people.
So these three
developers and designers
were asked to go to
the city, and help
solve a problem with technology.
And what they
heard over and over
was that they wanted them
to fix the city's website.
It was several-- I think it was
tens of thousands of web pages,
without any CMS backing it.
It was sort of a mess.
And they said in a
year, the three of us
are not going to
be able to do this.
Let's find a different
problem that we could solve.
But both the people that
they were talking to,
the residents of Honolulu
and the people in government,
kept coming back and saying, you
know, this is really a problem.
So they decided to dig
into it and just see
what the problem was.
So at the time, this is what
Honolulu.gov looked like.
Honolulu.gov is sort of a
classic government website.
We're starting with government,
the agencies and departments
that are represented.
The center panel, of
course, is news releases.
It's classic, what
government wants
to tell you about
what's going on.
The fellows decided,
let's start with data.
That's probably a much
better place to start.
So they looked at
the search logs.
And they said, what are
people searching for?
Turns out the top
search term-- I'm sorry,
you certainly can't
read this in the slide--
is driver's licenses.
Why would you be searching
for driver's licenses?
Well, A, most people don't
know what level of government
does what.
But actually in Honolulu,
the city and county
does handle the
driver's licenses,
because it's most
of the population.
And so they said, OK,
if that's the case,
let's figure out
how somebody would
find that information
on this site.
If you type driver's license
into Honolulu.gov circa 2012,
you would get a page
that looks like this.
You would get a page
You would get about 20
pages that look like that.
There is a lot of information
about driver's licenses
that we serve up
to our citizens.
And it's things like
that last paragraph that
explains to you that if
you're a returning service
member from overseas, you've
got an extra couple of months
after your driver's
license is expired
before you need
to get it renewed.
There's stuff about
the new machines that
are printing the new
driver's licenses.
But nowhere on this
site does it actually
tell you how to get
a driver's license.
So the fellows decided that
they could fix this problem.
And they built-- instead
of fixing the site,
they decided just to start
fresh with an interface that
is as we like to say, simple,
beautiful, and easy to use.
And they created the
content that they
thought citizens needed to find.
So if you type "driver's
license" into Honolulu.gov,
you get this.
How do you get a new license?
Where you go-- where you
go, what you need to bring,
and how you make an appointment.
Boom.
This is what
citizens actually are
looking for when they're
coming to government websites.
Now that beautiful
interface was directly
borrowed from our
friends in the UK.
The Government
Digital Service there
is doing amazing things
showing to the world
that this stuff can work
and can work well, not just
information, but
transactions and services.
And so they really
borrowed the technology.
The Government Digital
Service over there
was started when
they had-- and this
may sound familiar-- a $10
billion failure in health IT,
and decided that there
had to be a better way.
So they hired a
really fantastic guy
named Mike Bracken, who had
been the head of digital
for "The Guardian" to run it.
They gave him the
power and the authority
to actually do the right
thing with technology.
And now over there
in the UK, they
are spending about a sixth
of what they were before,
to have more visitors
to their site--
and frankly, much
happier visitors.
They're getting the
information they need.
But so back in Honolulu,
you have folks here
who are creating this
content and putting it
into a beautiful interface.
But they know that they can't
do all of that work themselves.
They built the content for
only like the top 10 searches,
that they saw on the site.
And then they said, we're going
to have to have a hackathon.
But they didn't need
any code written.
They needed content written.
So they held a write-a-thon.
This is the wall on
the co-working space,
a couple of blocks from
City Hall in Honolulu,
where they wrote out
all the questions that
were sort of suggested by the
rest of the top search terms.
You want to pull that over here?
And they invited a
lot of the people
that they'd met through
their residency in Honolulu
where they were going
around and telling
people what they were doing.
They invited workers
from City Hall.
And they got together over
the course of a Saturday
in the middle of 2012, and
these people in Honolulu
got together and wrote the
answers to those questions.
They would share
them back and edit
them, make sure they
were simple and clear.
They would run them by the
folks in city government
to make sure that
they were accurate
and they put them
into Honolulu Answers.
And at the end of
the day, pretty much
most of the questions
that citizens need
answered were in this interface
as a sort of alternative
to Honolulu.gov.
And more importantly, this
people had a fantastic time.
At the end of the day, they
were drinking, having fun.
The mayor stopped by
and hung out with them.
And I think it was
probably the first time
that I realized that government
technology was actually
like a party.
And these people not only felt
like they'd enjoyed themselves,
but they now feel
owners of the site.
And they felt like they were
helping their fellow citizens
in a way, using skills that
they had, not just tech skills.
So that basic interface is
now in about a dozen cities
around the country.
On National Day of Civic
Hacking two Junes ago,
Tim and I went to
a co-working space
a block from Oakland
City Hall, and worked
on a very similar project.
Tim did a great answer about
how you take paint to the dump.
Mine was about chickens.
Everyone asks me, isn't
it illegal to keep
chickens in Oakland?
No, it's not illegal.
You can keep
chickens in Oakland.
You just can't have roosters.
You don't want them.
They're very loud.
So this is now replicated
all around the country
by citizens, by the
people, but for the people.
For the people who
are going to use it.
This is a screenshot from
our site from ages ago.
It's in many more places now.
But those three things I think
are really illustrated here.
This notion that
the interfaces can
be much more beautiful
and easy to use.
The notion that people
don't just need to complain,
they can help.
And the fact that these
solutions can spread.
And when you think
of those things,
I think you start to believe
in our mission statement, which
is that government can work.
You can stop there, and
we're pretty controversial.
We believe that
government can work
for the people-- for
actual real people--
by the people, helping
out in the 21st century,
using these solutions.
But it's not going to
happen, because we complain.
It's not going to
happen, because we
are frustrated and
yell, and advocate
for government to
do differently.
It's going to happen because
we the people, make it happen.
So I have spent the
past couple of years
just trying to get
people to believe this,
trying to tell stories that
illustrate what's possible.
And then last April I was asked
to come serve in the White
House as the Deputy
Chief Technology Officer.
And I got there and start
working on this idea
that we could replicate what
they had done in the UK,
with the government
digital service there.
Brought the best talent
from the tech industry
to solving these problems,
and doing it right.
But I was there a couple of
months when this happened.
Healthcare.gov launched,
and then crashed.
And actually, I think there
were many other people here
who know a little bit
about this process.
When the site went down,
it was October 1st.
I was out here working on
the previous Code for America
Summit, because the
government was shut down
and I was furloughed.
It was a very
frustrating place to be.
Because this enormous
thing was happening,
and I was in the center of all
of the people who could fix it.
And I wasn't
allowed to even talk
to my boss for several weeks.
So it felt from the
west coast, kind
of like this-- just like, oh my
god, somebody fix the problem.
And on the other hand, here
we were, around all the people
looking for a-- you know, it's a
barn raising, it's a hackathon.
That's how we do things
in Silicon Valley.
Why can't we come out and help?
Now of course, people
did come out and help.
Todd Park, my boss, recruited
people primarily from Google
to come fix the site.
And we'll talk a bit about that.
But first I want to
answer this question I've
been asked so many times,
which is why did the site fail?
Most people believe that--
from outside the tech industry,
the question I
get most often is,
how could it have
possibly failed?
Didn't it have enough money?
It must have been underfunded
and under-planned.
It was absolutely
neither of those things.
It was over-funded and
it was over-planned.
And when I say
"planned," I mean this.
And I will not lecture
to a Google crowd
about the challenges of
waterfall development.
But this is de rigueur.
This is standard operating
procedure in government,
that we do all of the
planning up front.
And when we do that--
Clay Shirky had
a great line about
this-- actually he and I
talked a lot during the year.
And he wrote up an article
in "Foreign Affairs" where
he explained that the waterfall
method amounts by a pledge,
to a pledge by all parties,
not to learn anything
while doing the actual work.
Waterfall method is
what we do in DC,
not just because it's
what's comfortable there,
but because we have a
culture of legislation.
It's sort of as if you wrote
the rules around search quality
or spam control once--
when Google started,
and it was written
into legislation.
In order to change how you
interact with your users,
you had to go to Congress.
It's a very fundamental,
difficult problem.
But it is rooted not just in
the fact that we run the country
through legislation, but
through a culture that
assumes the things
get written once,
and then don't get changed.
So we do all of our
planning, and then we
execute to that plan,
whether it's working or not.
And it certainly
was not working.
The other reason that we
do government technology
through waterfall
development methodology,
is that we have this thing
called the Federal Acquisition
Regulation.
It is something like
2,600 pages long.
And it's the regulation
that tells us
how we buy things in
federal government.
Well, that unfortunately also
means how we buy technology.
And it says a lot
of things in there
about-- if you think about
it, if you were a buyer,
you want to know what you were
buying before you bought it.
So that has been
interpreted as, well, we
must know everything
the software is going
to do before we have any
interaction with a vendor--
which of course is going to
lead to that kind of problem.
Problems like this and
others have contributed
to what many think is about a
94% failure rate in federal IT.
I know that sounds
like a crazy number.
I think it's actually true.
If you looked at
the number of things
that did work, but
actually cost so much
more than any confident
technologist would think
it should cost, they're
probably all failures,
I think in some way.
And the ones that are successes
run very much under the radar.
They just simply don't
go through the process.
But I think the more fundamental
point about the failure
of government IT
is this, yes, we
are upset when our taxpayer
dollars aren't spent well.
Especially when we know it
could be done so much better.
But there is a deep anxiety that
our society exhibits when we
realize that we cannot
actually govern,
if we can't implement the
policies that we create.
And if you think about the years
leading up to Healthcare.gov,
the passage of the
Affordable Care Act,
and all of the political will
that went into passing that--
and then to think that
it almost went away--
we actually almost
lost that policy,
because we could not put
up a website that works.
Then you really see
that our inattention
to the federal
government landscape,
is threatening our ability to
have a functioning democracy.
Have I sacred you enough yet?
Are you terrified?
AUDIENCE: It's not a surprise.
JENNIFER PAHLKA: You should be.
Yes, its not a surprise.
But it is something we
have to come around to.
So when Healthcare.gov
failed, and I
was on the other side of the
country sort of freaking out,
I remembered this blog post
the Tom Steinberg had written
a year or two earlier,
about a colleague of his
who was an absolute genius.
The guy was at Poly Math.
He could have done anything
in the world that he wanted.
But he had dedicated his
life to civic technology.
And sadly Chris
Lightfoot had died,
and five years later,
Tom was memorializing him
with this blog post, where
he talks about this--
why Chris dedicated
his life this way.
And he said, what Chris
fundamentally had right,
was the understanding
that you can no longer run
a country properly, if the
elites don't understand
technology in the same way
that they grasp economics
or ideology, or propaganda.
And if you think about
when you were growing up--
and I don't know--
whatever age you are,
who were the people who were
going to go into government?
Lawyers, economists--
digital people
didn't go into government.
Now that's going
to have to change.
And he says, Chris'
analysis and predictions
about what would happen if
the elites couldn't learn
were savage and
depressingly accurate.
And I think that
what he's saying
is that he was predicting
Healthcare.gov,
here and in Britain.
And that there is something
truly scary about a country
that cannot implement
its own policies.
Savage and
depressingly accurate.
Yes, but the story got
better, as you all know.
This is what it
Mikey Dick-- I took
this slide from Mikey Dickerson.
I hope many of you know, but
Healthcare.gov is slightly less
terrible today.
Best headline ever.
That was a couple months in,
and then of course by April,
Obamacare had enrolled over 8
million people, which is more
than we even thought would
be enrolled in the program
before the site failed,
an absolute miracle.
How did they do that?
They did the opposite of
what we've done before.
They said that the
geeks must come,
and they must be in charge.
They brought tech
talent to government.
That's my Mikey there,
who-- I'm sure many of you
know Jeannie Kim,
also a former Googler.
[INAUDIBLE] my colleague
in the White House.
And Todd Park,
hiding behind there.
They came to government
and they said,
we are going to
take this seriously.
We, the people must come,
and we can do better.
The thing that you should know,
in case you haven't heard it.
And maybe can you
raise your hand
if you've heard
Mikey speak before?
OK, not everybody has.
The thing you should know
about that team, Googlers
and non-Googlers, is that it was
like they were fighting a war.
I saw Paul Smith a couple weeks
in, and asked about his family.
And he couldn't answer me.
He said, please don't talk to
me about anything personal right
now.
Because he had been
working for 20 hours a day,
for about 100 days.
Mikey did the same thing.
And when you do that,
you become exhausted.
And they did this for a reason.
They did this because they
knew that people in the country
needed health care.
And that they weren't going
to get it if the site failed.
I think that they are
true American heroes.
I think everybody who
came to solve this problem
really deserves not
just our admiration,
but are true gratitude.
How did they actually
do it though?
Because it was as we
say, a giant cluster.
I mentioned all
the planning that
happens in a waterfall process.
They just threw the plan out.
And they started
listening to the users.
They were absolutely
laser-focused on what the user
experience was, and just
making the site a little bit
better every day, based on
what they could actually
see people trying to do.
The other moment that I
really remember so well
from that year, was coming into
the office very late at night.
And Ryan [INAUDIBLE]
was there-- one
of the people who was
working with Mikey.
And we were talking
about-- we were talking
about the people who
need health care.
And he explained to me that at
about 3 o'clock in the morning
every night, the
site-- Healthcare.gov
was getting an enormous
amount of traffic
from very low-end smartphones.
Because the people
who need health care
often don't have
access to the internet.
And they don't have nice
iPhones and Android phones.
And they have multiple jobs.
And they knew-- they
were smart enough
to know that the load would be
lighter at 3:00 in the morning.
So they would get up in
the middle of the night,
and try to make it
through Healthcare.gov
on a low-end smartphone.
And they would get a little
bit further each time.
And that's how we got
to that eight million.
Just think about who goes
on a site like that at 3:00
in the morning.
It'll give you a sense of the
people that they were helping.
The other way they did it, was
to get a little bit as we say,
sharp elbows.
Mikey, famously, threatened
to punch people in the face,
in order to get basic
monitoring on the site.
He didn't actually punch
anyone's face, that was great.
But the experience that
that team had really
resonated with me.
Because I had just
left Code for America.
We were starting to work
on these very same issues.
And Ezra Klein put it really
beautifully in an article
about Healthcare.gov,
when he said
that too often the press and
the general public, of course,
really doesn't even know
the pain and the trouble
of interfacing with
government bureaucracy,
that the poor struggle
with every day.
So when Mikey and
Ryan were talking
about those people going on the
site at 3:00 in the morning,
it reminded me of the
work that I had just
been exposed to through
our team in San Francisco.
Watch this animation.
This is just part of the process
that you will go through,
if you try to apply for food
stamps in San Francisco.
I'm going to do
that again for you,
because it's so
much fun to watch.
It's a lot of information
that we collect.
And did you see this,
here at the end?
It's over 50
screens, just a site.
And you know what you
do at the end of that?
Can you see that middle button?
It says print.
You're going to print it.
And you're gonna fax it in.
And you're going to take it in.
And that's just going
to get re-entered.
This is how you apply
for food assistance
in the state of California.
And we found out about
this through a team
who was working with the
city and county of San
Francisco on this problem
of Churn in food stamps.
So once you do all
of that, and then
a bunch of other interviews, a
bunch of other proof of income
and things like that.
You become enrolled
in the program,
and what happens then is you
almost immediately fall off
the roles.
Almost everybody who applies
then is off the rolls
pretty quickly there after.
Which results in the
following, people
will be at the front of the
line at the checkout counter
with their EBT card, electronic
benefit transfer-- what
we used to call food
stamps, it's now a card.
They will have all of
their groceries packed up,
and they're ready to go.
They slide their card,
and it doesn't work.
Very often, this again is
in the middle of the night.
It's happening at midnight.
Because that's when you think
your card has been recharged.
Who goes shopping at midnight?
Hungry people go
shopping at midnight.
And they don't even know that
their cards doesn't work.
And the reason why, is because
they've gotten several notices
in the mail that look like this.
This actually one
of the nicer ones.
And I'm going to read it to you.
Because I feel like
torturing you today.
"Your food stamp
benefits in this quarter
did not change, as a result
of the document/information
we received,
because it would not
have resulted in an
increase in benefits."
Your food stamp
benefits in this quarter
do not change as a result of the
document or information we've
received, because-- it goes
on like this for pages.
And somehow from this,
you were supposed
to determine-- know that
you need to call the office
and provide some more
of that documentation.
I don't get that
from this language,
and neither does anybody else.
But this is how we
communicate with people
who need food
assistance in our state.
And so when you get that,
you don't do anything.
Once you're on
the program again,
you need to find out
where you can actually
spend your benefits.
And this is one of the
interfaces you go through
to try to find somewhere
that will take your card.
It's not the worst
thing in the world.
But it's not the most
beautiful thing either.
And of course,
it's browser-based.
So you're probably doing
this on a smartphone.
OPERATOR: (VOICEOVER) Welcome
to the California EBT--
JENNIFER PAHLKA:
This is how you try
to get your balance, to figure
out how much is your card.
OPERATOR: (VOICEOVER)
--card number,
followed by the pound sign.
JENNIFER PAHLKA: You call in,
you type in your remember.
[DIAL TONES]
JENNIFER PAHLKA: I think
I've tortured you enough.
I'll move on.
You don't have to listen
to the whole thing.
So these are small things.
I'm borrowing this from
wonderful Jake Solomon,
who worked on this.
These don't seem like
that big of a deal.
But especially if you're
poor, they really add up.
There are 3 and
1/2 million people
who are eligible for CalFresh,
our state's Nutrition
Assistance program,
but not getting it
because it's really difficult
to get on the program.
The welfare recipients are
paying about $20 million
a year, just in the
state of California
in ATM fees, which goes
straight to the bank.
So if you're on food assistance,
and you're paying $3.50 to use
it.
Most importantly,
when you do have
that-- you need to call the
office to stay on the program,
you are often on
hold for hours--
you know, for at least half
an hour, often an hour,
before you can even
talk to somebody.
And it's not just the
digital interfaces.
This is somebody
applying for the program.
They're using a pencil
that's too small,
on a wall that isn't flat.
It's just indicative over and
over again of the experience
that we put people through.
These are the bathrooms
in the Human Services
Agency in San Francisco.
It's a full experience
that's not very pleasant.
The good news is, this is
the Code for America team
that's working on this problem.
The guy in the glasses, in front
of the women in the blue shirt,
is the person who led
the challenge in 2012,
to fix this problem of Churn
in the food stamps program.
Others are Fellows that have
come to the program in 2014
along the bottom row, who are
working on super-utilizers
in the ER, in Long
Beach, California.
And others, who just
sort have come together
to work on some
of these problems
that I'm going to show you.
Sorry.
The super-utilizer is
people who need health care.
They don't have health care.
And so they go to the
ER over and over again.
They're there for
very basic care.
And if you give them the
services that they need,
which often aren't
health, right?
Often they are basic,
social services.
It's not that hard to keep them
from returning from the ER,
but what we generally do is
just let them come to the ER.
There are people who go to the
ER 100 to 150 times a year.
It's very high cost,
obviously to the system.
And very high cost
to the individual.
So I'm gonna show
you a couple things
that this team's
been trying to do
over the past year and a half.
This is that notice
that we talked about.
What Jake found to do through
many different efforts
on this Churn problem--
not the first thing,
but eventually what
he landed on to do,
was a very basic text
message that these folks get.
They still get those
terrible notices.
But when they're about
to fall off the roles,
they now get a text message that
says your CalFresh benefits may
stop at the end of this month.
If you have questions, call us.
So the people who were enrolled
in this program, 40% fewer
fell off the rolls
because of Promptly.
And when they don't
fall off, they
don't have to go through
that incredibly long process
of reapplying.
This is Alan Williams.
He was a fellow with us in 2013,
working on something completely
different-- on essentially
a GTFS, for trails,
an open trails
standard specification.
But he became excited
about the work
that his team was
doing on food stamps,
and so when the
fellowship ended,
he decided to not
take any income,
and enroll in all
the social services
that he could apply for.
So he spends a lot
of time on the phone,
trying to get his services.
OPERATOR: (VOICEOVER)At
this time,
operators are still
helping callers.
So please continue to
hold, and your call
will be answered by our
next available operator.
OPERATOR:
(VOICEOVER)The estimated
wait time is 20 to 40 minutes.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JENNIFER PAHLKA: So he
spends a lot of time on hold.
But he understands
the experience
that people in the
system are getting.
So the first thing that he did
is, remember that-- actually,
let me back up here.
Oh, it doesn't look
like I did the new deck.
The first thing that
he did is worked
on a what we call,
Clean, which is
a five-screen application
for food stamps,
instead of a fifty-screen
that works really well
on a basic smartphone.
Boom.
So compare that to
what you saw before.
And you don't have
to print it, exactly.
Though when they get
it in the office,
they still print it, which is
something we're working on.
This is a very simple
way of figuring out
where you can spend
your EBT cards.
This is a very simple way that
you can find out the balance.
You just simply text
in your EBT card.
We have a very funky thing
going on in the back end
to figure out what it is.
And then we text it back to you.
Boom.
And connect in such a way that
you don't have to wait on hold.
So you text in, you text
in your phone number
to CalFresh to connect,
and it tells you,
great, I'm going
to call the HSA,
the Human Services
Agency, for you.
And when there's someone
who can speak to you,
it calls you back.
Now if you don't have unlimited
minutes on your phone,
as most of those people
don't, this is a big deal.
And when you're trying
to work two jobs
and get your kids to school,
it's a really big deal.
The thing that I
love about this,
is this did not happen through
the Human Services Agency
in San Francisco.
The guys just did this.
They're We sort of pulled
back into the fold.
But they were
literally just doing
this in sort of an
activist capacity.
But when Jake, who had worked
on this Churn problem with HSA,
told Leo O'Farrell,
the head of HSA
in San Francisco about
this Connect product,
Leo said, that's fantastic.
One requirement though.
It has to be my voice
on the line that
tells the social services
worker to hold the line.
Or else they will hang up.
He insisted on saying,
this is Leo O'Farrell.
I have a client for
you on the line.
Please hold.
When we think that people
in government don't care,
were wrong.
They do.
They just need help.
When you give it to them,
they want to engage.
They're really an
amazing group of people.
So these little things,
I think are adding up,
to something of a better
experience for people
who have to deal with
government technology.
I think in California now, we're
making a bit of a difference.
But we are really still
nibbling at the edges
of an enormous problem.
Government IT in this--
this is an old stat.
I think it's about $180
billion dollars that we're
spending on government
IT right now.
And the results
speak for themselves.
They're just simply not--
we're not getting anywhere
near $180 billion of value.
Of course the good news-- the
United States Digital Service,
the unit of the executive
office president,
that I went to DC to set
up, is up and running.
And Mikey Dickerson
is leading it.
I can't think of a better
person to do this work.
He'll threaten to punch people.
And he cares about
the American public.
They're doing amazing work.
We also publish this United
States Digital Services
Playbook, that explains
to folks in government
how you can get better
results, for much less money.
I spent most of the
time that I was there
on number four, a
billed services that
use agile and
iterative practices.
Because the Office of
Federal Procurement Policy,
that manages Federal
Acquisition Regulation,
needed to understand that
this is actually legal.
And so in conjunction with
the Digital Services Playbook,
we also published something
called the TechFAR Handbook,
that tells contacting
officers and others who
work in the field
of procurement,
why this is legal, how to do
it, and make sure they're very
clear that at the
end of the day,
the authority on procurement
is the Office of Federal
Procurement Policy.
And when they put this
out that literally says,
we are helping you
build digital services
with a particular focus on how
to use contractors to support
an iterative customer-driven
software development
process, as is routinely done
in the private sector, that's
change.
It's going to take
us a long time
to see the results
of that change.
But that's fundamental
change that you
should be excited about.
I do want to question the
notion that this is innovation.
I think this is the basics.
Government should be able to
ship a website that works.
And we should not wrap it
in the banner of innovation.
It sort of degrades the notion
of innovation in my book.
But I do want to
return to this idea
that government can innovate.
And I think that the most
innovation that's happening
isn't in this sort of battle
between the west coast tech
wizards and the east coast
protectors of the way
it used to be.
But all around the country.
This is of map of the
brigades in the United States.
A Code for America
brigade is a group
of volunteers who meet
generally on a Tuesday
night in City Hall.
They are developers,
they're designers,
they're just random
citizens who can write,
whatever-- who work
with their cities
to make technology better,
and make the citizen
experience better.
So they do things like
open data portals,
and help with open
data policies.
They will stand up apps.
They can implement
any of the things
that I just showed,
for people who
use food assistance
in their city.
It's very easily redeployable.
They're doing a
wide range of things
that the city
themselves can't do.
So not only are they
helping the city,
helping the citizens
of the city,
but the real impact
that they have
is that the people in government
see this, and go, wow, maybe
we could do better.
There's innovation happening
all around the country.
This is an example of a project
that the Code for America
Fellows worked on in Charlotte,
North Carolina this year.
It's a very quick video.
But I think of it as
somewhat innovative in a way
that I kind of think
about Google right now.
I'm sure there's many, many
more innovative things happening
at Google.
But I love that
my phone tells me
when I'm supposed to leave
for an appointment now.
I didn't ask it to.
It just started doing that.
But that notion of let's
get information to a person
exactly when they need it is
sort of innovative these days.
And so the folks in
Charlotte asked our team
to build something that
looks a little bit like-- oh,
I have to click this.
Sorry about that.
You select the kind of thing
you want notifications about,
and then in the next screen, it
gives you a map of your city.
And you can custom draw whatever
geography is relevant to you.
So you may want to know
about special events
across the whole city.
You may want to know
about new businesses just
on the three blocks
right where you live.
It lets you do that.
And then asks for your
cellphone or email,
and it texts you or
emails you when there's
a traffic incident, or a
water service, or whatever,
just in the area that
you've written about,
that you've defined.
Here's a great thing--
and I'm actually
going to try to go over
and demo it for you.
A bunch of Fellows
this year decided
that we need to have a much more
broad dialogue about transit,
especially here
in San Francisco.
And they built something that
really looks like a tool.
I'm gonna demonstrate it
for you really quickly.
You can load up any city.
I'll use San Francisco here.
But just hit start.
And you can draw any
transit line you want.
So you're going to put
in your transit line.
I zoomed out.
So this is a very short line.
And it'll tell you how much
it costs per year-- sorry,
now I've got to stop.
And basically people
all over the country
have been using this.
Let me see if I have-- oh,
I didn't put in an example.
They're making transit maps
the way they want them to be,
all over the country.
And in fact, they're
competitive about it.
In Seattle, is in these
people's are competing
to do better transit map you
could just load the current map
and then add it or you can
start with your own lines.
But it's something that
really, when it came out,
these sort of urbanist
publications picked it up.
And they talked about
it as a toy or a game.
And it is, it's really fun to
play-- not that I showed that
very well.
But what we found is
that actually, especially
in small cities around
the country-- remember,
there are 30,000 municipalities
in this country--
it has become, in just a few
short months, the tool they
are using.
The enterprise tool that
small cities are using.
It's displacing--
it's just displacing,
really in many cases, these
enormous spreadsheets that
grow up over time.
But also these enterprise tools.
So I do see signs of true
innovation in government.
There's many, many more.
I'm not going to go
into all of them,
with the time that we have.
But I will return
to this notion,
that it's not just
about this idea
of for the people from
the "Gettysburg Address."
But it really is, when you look
at people like Mikey and Jake,
who are doing this.
They're doing it
because government
can work for people--
real people who
need to interact with
government, and not
just the poor.
We all have to interact
with government
at some point in our lives.
And when you think
about the people,
it becomes much more real.
And of course, by actual real
people who are doing this work.
The other way that
I really stress
we must think about this,
is without that middle.
Government can work
if we make it so.
It's only going to happen, if
we come together and actually do
it, which is why I will
and on an ask to you.
We are just a
couple of years old.
We've gotten amazing
support for the work
that we've done so far.
But there is so incredibly
much more that we need to do.
The first thing I would
ask Googlers to do
is to-- and excuse me,
because I know that recruiting
is difficult all
over the Valley,
and all over the tech
industry-- but take a year off
and do this with us.
Our Code for America
Fellowship program
is a year out of your life.
We've had I think four
Googlers do it so far.
We'd like to have 40 more do it.
We'd like to have
400 more do it.
It's an amazing experience.
You will learn and
do, and see things
that you would never
thought you would do.
[INAUDIBLE], who did
it two years ago,
ended up learning a lot about
the criminal justice system.
And that's something I
could do a whole talk on.
It's a fantastic experience.
And our 2015 class
is already set.
So the next opportunity
would for you
to apply in the middle
of 2015 for 2016.
But I would love to
talk to you about it,
if it's something you'd
be interested in doing.
We're able to do our work
because the tech industry has
done very well for itself.
And we hope that people
will consider donating,
so that we can do
more of this work
for the people who need it.
It's not the only way that
you can get involved though.
We recently-- well, we did not
launch-- Ron Bouganim recently
launched the first
ever Govtech fund.
It's a venture fund just for
companies that are actually
going to disrupt in a good
way, the civic ecosystem,
or government
technology ecosystem.
So I would encourage
any of you who
are thinking about
doing businesses,
to look at that
$180 billion market.
A lot of that is going to
change over the coming years.
And the companies that are going
in there to offer services,
that look like the kind
of work that you do here,
are going to be
extremely successful.
There's also
obviously opportunity
to invest in
companies like that.
And then there's a million
sort of casual ways
that you can help.
On our site right now, you
can find our civic tech issue
finder.
So if you wanted to go, say,
take an hour tonight and code
on a project that has an open
issue across our network--
which includes not just
Code for America projects,
but across the civic
tech ecosystem.
So Sunlight Foundation
has projects on there.
You can pretty
easily find something
that might need your help.
Do a little help, and
feel good about yourself.
But to me-- and whatever
you do, the point is,
we are all told every day that
we are primarily consumers,
that our job is to buy things.
But we really have to
live like citizens.
And understanding that
your government needs you
is part of that.
Thank you very
much for having me.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: OK.
So a couple questions--
one is maybe could you
go to the like-- so
first of all, the story,
the Mikey Dickinson story
is pretty inspiring.
But it's also reflects
a pretty extreme level
of personal sacrifice--
I presume most people who
are applying this
thing, probably
wouldn't be committing
to that level.
So maybe you can
talk about like,
what sort of things
you're looking for?
JENNIFER PAHLKA: Mm hm.
AUDIENCE: And the second
is, what's the process?
I mean, I went to his
previous tech talk,
and it was like, well, if you're
interested, send us an email.
And I think for people on the
fence, that's probably not
really enough.
You kind of want to know
what you're getting into,
before taking a step
like that, and saying,
I'm going to do this.
JENNIFER PAHLKA: Right.
Sure, so yeah.
No, most people don't--
aren't working on something
that's on the front page of
the paper every single day,
and therefore is pretty intense.
In fact, I wish in many
cases that more projects
were that urgent.
Because then they would
actually get fixed.
But Mike Bracken, who runs the
Government Digital Service is
always teasing us
about the way Americans
do things is through crisis.
The way Britain does, we
actually get ahead of the game.
But if you look at what's
going on in federal government
right now, and in
local government,
it's not 20 hour days,
100 days straight.
There's a whole
team now under 18F,
which is the sort
of implementation
arm of our digital services
play, in federal government.
They've got about 50 people
now doing digital services,
right in the federal government.
And they work regular
hours on projects
that aren't about to kill
the president's major policy
agenda.
So yeah, it is mostly
sort of normal jobs.
I would also say that I think
Mikey's intake form, which
is still up-- you
probably have all seen it.
It's still a great way to just
sort of signal your interest.
If you're interested
in Code for America,
we've got a lot on
the side about what
it's like to be a Fellow,
that you can look at.
You could also talk to me.
And then the problem with
the federal government stuff,
if it just depends on
where you want to go.
But starting by putting your
email out there, and someone
will contact you,
is a good way to go.
I'm happy to talk to you more
about what your interests are.
AUDIENCE: This is--
Google is my first company
outside of government.
Previously I worked in
NYC Digital, and also--
JENNIFER PAHLKA: Oh, cool.
AUDIENCE 3: --in
the White House,
as the Secretary of the
Presidential Innovation
Committee, before you arrived.
JENNIFER PAHLKA: Oh, great.
AUDIENCE: And so
I think we share
a lot of common interests.
And the reason I left was
because of the Snowden
revelations.
And I just found that
I couldn't convince
people to trust the
government with--
JENNIFER PAHLKA: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --with their data,
in a way that I could before.
And l sort of lost hope.
So I'm wondering if in the
year that you were at the White
House, was there any push-back
from OSTP against NSA
surveillance?
And do you have a message
for people like myself, who
want to still continue
to be in public service,
and use these skills
towards open data,
but don't know how to
rationalize mass surveillance?
JENNIFER PAHLKA: Sure.
It's a great question.
When I was at the White
House, I saw firsthand
the way that the tech
industry can and should
continue to use the
fact that, I think
the federal government gets that
its Silicon Valley that's going
to save it.
And yes, we should
use that as leverage
to ask for what's
right around the rest
of the federal government.
So the president,
while I was there,
held a meeting with some top
folks in the tech industry.
I believe your CEO was--
well, your CEO was there.
And the first part
of the meeting
was to talk about
digital services.
And the second part was
to talk about the NSA.
I was excused for the
second part of that.
Because there was a lot
of sensitive information
that was shared.
My personal belief on it-- and
I speak just as a citizen--
is that I'm not OK with
what is going on there.
On the other hand,
that's not an excuse
not to help the people in
our country who need help.
AUDIENCE: One question
from the Dory.
Jonathan Betts is asking,
how can lessons-- sorry,
I should-- how can lessons
learned through experiences
like Healthcare.gov scale
across all people and government
responsible for technology?
JENNIFER PAHLKA: I think
there's two levels of answer.
And the first one is, the
Digital Services Playbook--
and I showed a
screenshot of it--
is the lessons learned
from Healthcare.gov.
Well, and from every
other technology project.
But the failure
of Healthcare.gov
gave that a lot more prominence,
and a lot more political
power, than it would have if
we hadn't just had that crisis.
So the Playbook is now there.
It's a good playbook.
I think somebody on O'Reilly
Radar wrote it up as,
'not a playbook not just for
government, any private sector
company should
follow this playbook.
The problem is that you
can know what to do.
You can know what's
right, and still
have challenges
within a culture,
in a bureaucracy that's done
it differently for a long time.
And so in order
for those practices
to actually scale in
practice-- can I say that?
The practices of
scale in practice--
we need to support the
people in government
who run into obstacles.
And so Mikey's team is basically
piloting a way to do that.
That then they can take-- each
time they run into an obstacle,
whether it's a legal obstacle,
a [INAUDIBLE] obstacle, an HR
obstacle-- they're figuring out
how to sort of blow that up.
And then documenting
how they blew that up,
and then getting that out there.
So what's that great line?
The difference between
theory and practice
is always greater in theory
that it is in practice?
Did I say that right?
Practice than it is in-- OK.
Point is the recipe is there.
It's going to take a long time
before people are actually
following it.
And that's where,
again-- thank you
for the setup
question, Jonathan.
It comes back to,
it doesn't work
if you don't have
people who know
how to build digital
services that way there.
And don't accept a different
way of doing things.
And can normalize it.
And can say, well,
we won't-- you know--
I know that seems radical here.
But that really is how effective
digital services are built,
I guarantee it.
Then it makes people feel a
little bit more comfortable.
So we have to have the people
there to back up the playbook.
AUDIENCE: Working with
San Francisco is great.
And there's people
around here, at Google
who will come help out.
But how do you scale this
to sort of local governments
around the country?
There's so many.
And there's just
really not like-- it
seems like not enough tech
talent to take this abroad.
JENNIFER PAHLKA: Thank you, yes.
So the question of scaling
it to local governments
is what we spend
most of our time on.
Here, I'll hold it
for the next person.
Thanks.
So Steph mentioned our summit.
So the plan has been basically,
show what's possible.
Spread the stories
of what's possible.
Get more people interested.
And then give them the tools
to solve the problem as well.
But they first have to believe
that the old way is not
necessary, right?
That there's a better
way, and that it's doable.
And so we've been working
really hard on that.
Our Fellowship program itself
doesn't scale very well.
It's extremely intense.
What we can do though is
scale the outputs of it.
And so we've built a
series of other programs
that do that, including a
network of people in government
who sort of have
drunk the Kool-Aid.
Then we need to
empower them, to help
them pilot these things
in their own cities.
And in that essentially is
the play that we're running.
It gets a little bit more
sophisticated every year.
And it gets more sophisticated,
because we get more resources.
We have been a very,
very small organization.
Now we're about
almost at 40 people.
We could easily be 4,000
people, and we still
wouldn't have fixed the problem.
But we'll get there.
Because it's about
building the network.
It's not just us, right?
It's the people in
government who do it.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned the
criminal justice system.
JENNIFER PAHLKA: Mm hm.
AUDIENCE: And I think
it's, right now,
it's kind of an
interesting tipping
point in the public
consciousness,
about what-- about
reform, and I'm actually
working with a nonprofit
that's looking at helping--
or has specifically
asked Googlers or tech
people, to open up
some of the tracking
that we do for people that are
in the criminal justice system.
JENNIFER PAHLKA: We should talk.
AUDIENCE: But anyway,
I was wondering
since I don't have
a lot of time like,
is there anything specific in
the criminal justice system
that you guys are working
on that's exciting?
JENNIFER PAHLKA: Yeah,
thank you for asking that.
It's actually the area that
I'm most excited about.
We have identified three
areas of focus for our work
next year.
It doesn't mean we won't
do some other stuff.
But our Fellowship cities
and Fellows next year
are going to be focusing
on safety and justice,
economic development, and
health, which is really
the human services work, a
continuation of the stuff I
just showed.
I have become sort
of outraged I think,
at the way our criminal
justice system is working.
And it's absolutely
true that a lot of that
is due to terrible policy.
But an enormous amount of
it is due to incompetence
of the system.
We can't get people
out of jail--
you know, people who
are held pre-trial
that don't need to be.
There was the article
that you've probably
seen in The New Yorker about
the young man in New York, who
spent three-- who went
into Rikers at 16,
and was held without a
trial for three years.
A lot of that is
simply the system
can't just tie it's own
shoelaces in the morning.
There is an enormous
amount that we
could do using data to get
people not held pre-trial.
And there are all sorts of
follow-on effects to that.
If they're not held,
they're much more
likely to be not
convicted of the crime.
There's an enormous
amount that we
can do to keep people from
getting bench warrants.
So a bench warrant
is what you get
if you rode your
bike on the sidewalk,
and got a little teeny ticket
that shouldn't be a big deal.
But then you never
followed up on it,
and you never cleared it.
And suddenly the next
time you're pulled over
for something, boom,
you're in jail.
We have a lot of people
in the criminal justice
system for very, very petty
crimes that don't need to be,
if we can just make the
system work a lot better.
We are interested both in the
public safety side of it--
how can we make our
communities safer?
And then how can we make
that system far more just,
using data?
We did a jail
management dashboard
in Louisville,
Kentucky, that actually
[INAUDIBLE] who was a
Googler that worked on.
It was sort of
his major project.
That's now being
redeployed to Denver.
But it gets at like
this basic problem
that people literally don't
even know who-- they can't even
look at who is in
the jails, and manage
that population in any way.
We've done these
court date reminders.
So that people who need to show
up to clear a parking ticket,
can either just do it
through their mobile phone,
or can be reminded
that they actually
need to show up in court.
So they don't end up
getting a bench warrant,
and reduce the
number of people who
are like jamming up the system.
It is probably, after--
name the top things, NSA,
and Guantanamo River-- like one
of our biggest national shames
right now.
We should be terribly ashamed
of how our criminal justice
system works.
And we have to do better.
So we're going to focus
on that pretty heavily
in the coming three years.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]